how do you practice normal face so same
and the reason that group these two
questions together is because there's a
little there's some similarities there
you know how do you practice normal face
which is a legitimate skill by the way
yes sir it's it's oh it's funny little
game if you haven't heard of what you do
is I used to do some I kids I put line
them up and if they made any expression
whatsoever besides just a normal plain
face I'd hit him in the head with a the
inside cardboard roll-up of a wrapping
paper so that's there's the game and
it's a lot of fun and we'd have fun
doing it everyone laugh well it's also
useful as adult to be able to not show
your emotions so how do you do it same
thing put yourself in stressful
situations and you know a good one is
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu if you can just like
act normal even when someone's just
crushing you then that's a positive
thing it's like you know sometimes you
and I are rolling yes and you'll be like
oh I felt a sense of urgency yes that's
when I lose its failure to keep normal
face so I get a little bit scramble
because you're gonna pass or something
like that yeah and then you even you
feel all good cuz you have me react
broke my normal face so yes that's good
I would say the thing about normal faces
practice at all time you know where you
practice it and you practice it like
when you're driving I mean I do can't do
this anymore cuz when we started this
podcast I would get Pro questions all
the time about road rage yeah how do you
prevent road rage how do you promote
road I think everyone's so in the game
now but they're they figured it out but
that's a good you know any time where
there's something bad happening like
something annoying something like the
line yes the line line at the DMV the
line wherever and you just just just
keep normal face and just act like
whatever detach it act normal use money
in jiu-jitsu when you're in between
realms
mm-hm don't act tired yeah that second
one of my I try and maintain that rule
always hard you taught me that oh yeah I
don't even know if you meant to teach me
and I told the story before but yeah
we're here to get you we'd roll and I'd
be tired whatever after rolling with you
and then you know and people do this all
the time this sticks it's like a red
flag to me not a red flag warning it
just sticks out a lot when people do
this after the round they'll just flop
on their back
you know like breathing all hard kind of
just you know indicating that ho that
was a tiring round right anything yeah
you need to have tiring rounds like to
get it kind of thing this is the message
that you conveyed to me through your
actions you didn't tell me this but
through yeah so I roll with you and I do
that or something along those lines
right and you like stand up not
breathing through your mouth
I remember that you're just like you
know like mouth closed and then you
we're looking at me almost like you're
disappointed in me that was yeah you are
not thinking back yes I realize you
probably were and you said you look a
little tired
and then you just walked away mm-hmm
almost like that was the bad part the
the part that I looked tired that that
was like the bad part you didn't like
and I was like it from literally from
then on I'd act like I wasn't tired in
between even if I was sorry I've tried
to act like I'm not tired
actively that's so important mm-hm it's
important in life yeah you know it's
important as a leader it's way more
important as a leader than anything else
when you start to break thinking well I
don't know if you have an examples but
like I think of times in my life where I
would see my leaders start to break yeah
and just think like how horrible that is
for the rest of the team and I'd be
looking a leader that was breaking that
be like bad you aren't letting everyone
down and I you're not gonna do it to me
I'm gonna you know what actually this is
an opportunity for me if you're looking
weak I'm not gonna get all aggressive
but I'm gonna I'm gonna make sure that
people aren't gonna follow that attitude
because that attitudes gonna hurt us all
yeah so as a leader normal face is even
more important yeah I'm not saying you
never show emotions at this dichotomy
and I'm saying never no emotions as a
leader because you absolutely do show
emotions as a leader but you make sure
that they're controlled you make sure
they're not the most negative emotions
yeah
so am I saying to not be yourself yes I
am because if yourself is being a week a
week loser and you're in charge of a
team and you show everyone that you're
wrong no you need to stifle those
emotions which we've talked about before
you stifle those you need to act you
need to act like hey we're gonna make
this happen
yeah this doesn't mean lie to him this
isn't like hey
the boat sinking but don't worry were
it's gonna be okay no hey guess what
boats sinking you know we're gonna do
we're gonna break out a life jackets
going to form into a pool we're gonna
grab whatever we can't off this fast
we're gonna make sure you know what I
mean yeah how's supposed to the boats
sinking right yeah so you lead check so
if what like when your kid falls down
right yeah totally totally like yeah
wait Oh how's it I was at the park my
son two climbs up high on this thing is
like bit slanted jungle-gym kind of
things just slanted it's like pretty
high where it's not like so high that he
shouldn't be up there it's not that but
it's it's high where you got to keep an
eye on that thing right there and sure
enough he takes a step or whatever and
it just straight up falls to the ground
and the ground is the ground was like a
bunch of this weird hey kind of stuff so
it's it wasn't like concrete put it that
way but he fell down full-on and the
kind you know kind other parents are
looking and my wife is sitting right
next to me kind of far away me let a
grabber do yeah literally grabbed her
like don't run over and move and my
daughter was there she's super caring
too so I'm like I should have grabbed
her too but you so far away anyway so he
falls down of course doesn't cries more
like surprised in the Sun and looking
around almost with the look on his face
like how should I react okay that's
exactly what he's doing
yeah and then gentleman yeah it's all
good yeah I mean I don't want to react
yeah so ideally I mean my kids would
take a digger I'd start laughing that
was awesome
yeah and then they're like really yeah
yeah that was awesome we got a little
Skinner nice oh look you're bleeding ha
ha ha that's gonna leave a cool scar
yeah you're awesome welcome to the club
yeah that's a good one like so like poop
that's awesome kind of thing yeah I'll
be like oh I stand up strong hurry up
hurry up like kind of like you gotta
beat it in like show me how strong you
are kind of thing oh I did that the
other day nonetheless yeah so he got up
and he didn't cry and of course it was
the high asphalt to injury he landed
correctly her feet like he was taller
than I stand so so we're talking 7 feet
like 7
nice six-six yeah okay over over is it
digger yeah it was you solid yeah but he
landed good like if you were to land it
on his head that's an injury straight up
but yeah for sure he felt like good
which is lucky but yeah nonetheless so
yeah the point is if I were to like ran
over there or something like this it
would have jammed him up yeah isn't that
why the airline pilots when you get
turbulence they're like hey everybody
just go ahead and buckle your seat belts
we might feel a little bit more that you
know hey guys we're good yeah I very
much appreciate that when they do that
by the way